in this video you're going to learn how
to expand a binomial race to a power by
using the binomial theorem we're also
going to talk about how to use Pascal's
triangle as well as if you just want to
zero in and find a particular term in a
binomial expansion or even just find the
coefficient so we're going to go through
six problems I'll have some that you can
practice on your own we'll go through
all these together and I'll show you
some tricks and techniques as we go
through this just to pay attention to so
let's start off with this first one if
we want to expand 2x minus 3y to the
third power one way we could do this is
we could just think of 2x minus 3y
multiplied three times so we have three
of this group we'd have to foil two of
these together multiply them together
and then multiply by this last binomial
and then simplify so that's one way to
do it but the binomial theorem is
designed to make this a lot quicker
especially when you raise this to like a
higher power like four or five or six
Etc so what we're going to do is we're
going to talk about Pascal's triangle
and Pascal's triangle basically it
starts with one and each row starts with
one and ends with one okay you can see
that and then what we're doing is you're
adding the terms above it to get the
term below it so 1 plus 1 is 2 or 1 plus
2 is 3 or Etc and you keep working your
way down
but where these numbers can also be
derived from is from the combinations so
when you learn about permutations and
combinations remember the NCR out of n
items how many ways are there to choose
R of those items where the order doesn't
matter and we use this formula n
factorial Over N minus r factorial R
factorial so what you could do let's say
for example if you're down here at this
row okay which this is called the fourth
row it starts at row zero then it goes
one two three four you can tell what row
you're on if you just look at that
second number see this is the fourth row
or the third row that's the one way to
kind of help as you go further down but
this one here really comes from 4 C 0
out of four items how many ways are
there to choose zero where the order
doesn't matter well there's only one way
of choosing zero items out of four right
and then this one out of four items how
many ways are there to choose one item
or the order doesn't matter that's four
and out of four items how many ways
either to choose two where the order
doesn't matter that's six ways Etc
but what we're going to do is we're
going to use these coefficients to help
us in this expansion here so we can do
this a couple different ways one way to
do it is to start with uh this was to
the third power so we're going to start
with Row three here and these are going
to be our coefficients one three three
and one now remember where these come
from this is really the same thing as
three C zero three c one three C two and
three c three then what we do is we take
this first term 2x you want to take that
whole group here and you're going to
raise it to the third power and then
you're going to go in descending order
so 2x to the second 2x to the first 2x
to the 0 power then you take the second
term and you want to make sure you
capture that minus sign that negative
sign this is going to be negative 3y to
the 0th power
and then we're going to go in ascending
order so we're going to go up so
negative 3y to the first negative 3y to
the second negative 3y to the third now
I want to show you some patterns here
that are important to recognize notice
how this r value is 0 matches the second
term's power here zero see one one two
two three three that's important we're
going to use that a little bit later in
this video the other thing that's
important to remember is see these two
exponents three plus zero is three two
plus one is three one plus two is three
zero plus three is three now what we're
going to do is all these are terms are
going to be added together so just think
of a plus sign between all of these
terms let's go ahead and simplify so we
have 3 C 0 which is one
times 2x to the third power so this is
coming out to one
two cubed is eight so this is eight X
cubed
and anything to the zero power is one
okay so if we simplify that this comes
out to just eight x to the third power
okay the next term we have three c one
which is three
we have two squared which is four x
squared
negative 3y to the first of course
anything to the first is itself and so
now if we simplify this we get let's see
negative nine times four is negative 36.
x squared y okay and then for this next
term we've got 3c2 which is three
and we have
2x to the first anything to the first
powers itself negative 3 squared is nine
y squared okay so if we simplify that we
get 6 times 9 is 54 x y squared and then
the last one 3c3 is 1.
and anything to 0 here is one and then
negative three cubed is negative 27 y to
the third power so if we multiply all
that together we just get Negative 27y
cubed so all these terms are going to be
added together so our final result is
going to be 8 x to the third minus 36 x
squared y plus 54 x y squared minus 27 y
cubed and you've expanded it
and that's it now one thing to pay
attention to is see how this is
subtracting when you're subtracting like
this notice these terms alternate
positive negative positive negative if
they were both positive these would all
be positive all these terms and the
other thing to watch out for here is
that you can use the combinations like I
was showing you okay or you can just use
Pascal's triangle just go down here to
row number three again remember this
starts at row zero let's talk about
another example where you're just
zeroing in on a particular term not
doing the whole expansion let's look at
that next so how do we find the third
term in the expansion of 5x plus 7y to
the seventh power without having to
actually expand the whole binomial using
that binomial theorem well what we can
do is we can use that pattern we were
talking about earlier in the first
question we could say well if I want to
go down to the seventh row in Pascal's
triangle right
it would start off with 1 and then 7 and
then
Etc right but where are those numbers
coming from it would start off with
seven choose zero seven choose one seven
choose two Etc so the
third term here is actually going to be
7 c 2 Y2 because we're starting each row
with zero so this is going to be 7c 0 7
c 1 7c2 that's actually our third term
and then look at this pattern here we've
got our two terms 5x and 7y
but remember how we said that this r
value here and the exponent on the
second term they're always in lockstep
they always match and remember the
pattern where we said these two
exponents here are going to add up to
this power here the seven so in this
case this has to be to the fifth power
so now we've zeroed in on that
particular term all we have to do is
simplify so 7c2 you could do this on
your calculator if you have a
combination key on your calculator or
you can use the factorials this formula
here so I'll show you if you expand this
this would come out to 7 factorial
over
n minus r so that's going to be 7 minus
2 which is 5 factorial
and then R factorial which is going to
be 2 factorial okay then we're going to
say well 5 to the fifth which is
3125 x to the fifth seven squared that's
49.
y squared okay so continuing to simplify
down here now 7 factorial represents
seven times six times five times four
times three times two times one remember
the factorial tells you start at this
number you multiply down to one same
thing with 5 factorial that's 5 times 4
times 3 times 2 times 1 and 2 factorial
is 2 times 1. so notice the 5 4 3 2 and
1 cancel numerator denominator 7 times 6
is 42 2 times 1 is 2 42 divided by 2 is
21. so we have 21
times
this whole quantity
3125 x to the fifth
times 49 y to the second let's go to the
calculator and finish simplifying that
that's 21 times 3125 times 49 this is
coming out to a large number here this
is coming out to 3 2 1 5 6 2 5.
x to the fifth y to the second
and you've zeroed in in that particular
term now let's talk about a problem that
involves just solving for this
coefficient in front of the variables
let's do that in example three
find the coefficient of the X cubed y
squared term in the expansion of x minus
2y to the fifth power so how do we do
that well what I like to do is I like to
write down my two terms this is my first
term X this is my second term negative
2y
and I know the exponents here because I
know I want to end up with X cubed y
squared so this has to be to the third
power this has to be to the second power
but we're on the fifth row of Pascal's
triangle right so this is uh to the
fifth power so this is going to be 5 C
and remember the connection here between
this second terms exponent and this r
value so this has to be 5c2
so now we've zeroed in on the term but
we want to find out just the coefficient
the number that comes in front of this x
cubed y squared so let's simplify a
little bit more so 5c2 using our
combination formula is going to be 5
factorial over 5 minus 2 3 factorial
times 2 factorial this is going to come
out to X cubed and negative 2 squared is
going to come out to 4 y squared a
negative times a negative is 8 positive
4. now if we simplify here 5 factorial
is 5 times 4 times 3 times 2 times 1
3 factorial is 3 times 2 times 1 and 2
factorial is 2 times 1. so you can see
the 2 the 1 are canceling numerator and
denominator these threes are canceling
this comes out to 20. this comes out to
2 20 divided by 2 is 10. so we have 10
times 4 which is 40 x cubed y squared
we just want the coefficient so we're
just after this number that comes in
front here so your final answer would be
40. okay for example number four five
and six they're going to basically be
repeats of example one two and three so
see if you can do these problems on your
own we'll go through them together and
let's dive into number four now it says
expand 4X plus y to the fifth power well
if I was going to do this I would use
either the combinations or I would go
down to the fifth row in Pascal's
triangle so here previously I went down
just to the fourth row so remember each
row starts with one then I add the two
numbers
above it so one plus four is five four
plus six is ten six plus four is ten
again four plus one is five and one
remember it always begins with one and
ends with one one thing you'll also
notice is it's symmetric see one five
ten right okay so we're going to use
those coefficients one five ten ten five
and one remember where they come from
they really come from the five C zero
five c one the five C two five c three
five C four and five C five then we take
our first term here which is 4X and we
take that to the fifth power and we go
in descending orders so 4X to the fourth
four x to the third four x to the second
power four x to the first Power and four
x to the zeroth power then we take the
second term which is positive y or we
could say y we start at the zeroth power
and we go into ascending order meaning
we're going up
so y squared y to the third y to the
fourth y to the fifth and notice these
are all multiplied together and then
each individual term is added to the
next term so there's like a plus sign in
between each of these terms
so now let's go ahead and simplify this
down a little bit and so what do we get
it looks like we're getting 5c 0 which
is one
four to the fifth power I have to go to
the calculator on that one
it's 1024
x to the fifth
and then y to the zero anything to the
zero power is one
so one times one is one so this is just
coming out to 1024 x to the fifth that's
our first term in this expansion second
term we've got five c one which is five
and then we're got four to the fourth
power
which is 256.
x to the fourth y to the first
okay so if we multiply that together
that comes out to one thousand two
hundred and eighty x to the fourth y
5c2 that's 10 so we have ten four cubed
is 64. X cubed and Y squared so if we
multiply that together we get
640 X cubed y squared
and then for the next term 5c3 is 10 so
we have 10 4 squared is 16 x squared y
cubed so if we multiply that together
you can see we're getting 160 x squared
y cubed
this term 5c4 is 5 so we have five
times four x to the first is 4X y to the
fourth
and if we multiply that together we're
getting 20 x y to the fourth and the
last one 5c5 is 1. 4X to the 0 is 1 y to
the fifth so that just simplifies to Y
to the fifth and then all these terms
are added together now you can write it
horizontally I have it here vertically
normally we write it horizontally but
again notice some of the patterns here
see how this first term we had 5 C 0 and
this r value is matching with this
second term's power we also notice that
five plus zero is five or if I jump down
here see how this is like R value is 3
and the second term's power is three
they match two plus three is five see
that exponent that power so we're going
to use that in the next problem where we
zero in on just a particular term
without having to do the entire binomial
expansion find the fifth term in the
expansion of 2x minus 7y to the eighth
power so we don't want to take the time
to do the entire expansion we just want
to zero in on this fifth term but notice
this is to the eighth power so what we
could do is we could go down to the
eighth row of Pascal's triangle keep
expanding that would take a little bit
of time though the other way to do it is
we could use the combinations to help us
to write that eighth row and if we want
the fifth term knowing that this always
starts with zero
that's going to be
8c08c1 8c2 8c3 8c4 is actually going to
be for our fifth term notice it's one
less because we're starting at 0 right
here so this is going to be 8 that's
coming from this power okay that's the
row we go to C4 one less than the fifth
term because we're starting at zero then
we're going to take our first term which
is 2x our second term which is negative
7y and remember the pattern here this R
value and the second terms exponent they
match they're the same these two
exponents have to add up to this power
here eight so that means that this has
to be to the fourth power because four
plus four has eight
so now we've zeroed on that particular
term let's just go ahead and simplify so
8c4 using our combinations formula here
is going to be 8 factorial over eight
minus four four factorial
4 factorial okay 2 to the fourth we know
is 16 x to the fourth and negative seven
to the fourth let's do that on the
calculator
that's coming out to 2401
positive because a negative times
negative times a negative times a
negative an even number of times is
positive and so now let's simplify this
so 8 factorial is really 8 multiplied
all the way down to one
4 factorial is four times three times
two times one and this 4 factorial 4
times 3 times 2 times 1. you can see
these are canceling numerator and
denominator let's see four times two is
eight that cancels with this 8. 3 times
1 is 3 that goes into six twice 2 times
5 is 10 times 7 is 70. so we have is 70
times all of this so let's go ahead and
do that in the calculator Seventy Times
sixteen times two thousand four hundred
and one is giving us
two six eight nine one two zero
x to the fourth
y to the fourth and that's just that
particular term the fifth term in this
binomial expansion okay before we jump
into this next problem which I'm going
to actually have another problem after
this as well a bonus problem so we'll
actually have seven problems in this
video and congratulations for sticking
up with me this far you must be pretty
dedicated I just wanted to let you know
if you like the way that I'm explaining
things and you would like to learn more
about either Algebra 1 or Algebra 2
college algebra I have video courses for
sale with links in the description below
so check out those video courses if you
want to learn more about Algebra 1
Algebra 2 college algebra and if you
just want to support the channel
consider joining as a channel member for
a few dollars a month you can help
support the content that I'm putting up
here for you guys and I'd really
appreciate it so thank you for that but
let's jump into number six so can you do
this problem can you find the
coefficient meaning the number that
comes in front of this variable
expression x to the fifth y to the
second in the expansion of 3x minus 5y
to the seventh how would you do that one
well go ahead and pause the video see if
you can do it and in the meantime what I
would do is I would either go down to
the seventh row in Pascal's triangle if
I had that written out or I can use the
pattern of the combination so it would
start off with 7c07c1
Etc right and I know that I'm dealing
with these two terms here which are 3x
and negative 5y okay and I know that
these exponents have to be 5 because I
want to end up with X to the fifth and
this has to be two and this makes sense
because 5 plus 2 adds up to this
exponent here's 7. and again we're on
the seventh row and remember the pattern
where the second terms exponent is the
same as this R value right here so
that's a match so now all we have to do
is just simplify this 7c2 you can do
this on your calculator or you can use
the formula the NCR formula that would
be 7 factorial over seven minus two five
factorial two factorial
3 to the fifth is 243
x to the fifth and negative 5 squared is
25 y squared if we simplify this 7
factorial is 7 times 6 all the way down
to one
5 factorial is 5 all the way down to one
multiplied together and 2 factorial is 2
times 1. so you can see the five four
three two one cancel numerator and
denominator 42 divided by 2 is 21. so
this would be 21 times these other terms
so this is going to be 21
times 243 times 25
which comes out to 1 2 7 5 7 5 x to the
fifth y squared but we just want the
coefficient that's the number that comes
in front of x to the fifth y squared so
just the 127
575. let's go and take a look at a bonus
question here involving imaginary
numbers this is a little bit more
challenging see if you can do this last
problem
2 plus I to the fourth power how would
you expand that and the I represents the
imaginary I where it's the equals the
square root of negative one so how would
you expand that and simplify it write it
as a complex number in standard form a
plus bi form so this is uh kind of a
little bit more challenging but it's the
same idea you have a binomial two terms
we're on the fourth row right so this
would be one four six four and one those
are our coefficients so let's write that
down
and then we have two our first term to
the fourth power
2 to the third two to the second we're
going into descending order 2 to the
first and two to the zero we take our
second term which is I and we go into
the zeroth power and we go in ascending
order we go up
and then all we have to do here is
simplify so two to the fourth we know is
2 times 2 times 2 times 2 that's 16
times 1 is 16 anything to the zero is
one so this comes out to 16.
2 cubed is 2 times 2 times 2 that's 8
times 4 is 32 times I so that's I two
squared is 4 times 6 is 24.
I squared okay now I squared is how much
well I squared is equal to negative one
so it's I times I which is I squared
that's negative 1. so this would really
be equal to negative 24 because negative
1 times 24
and then I cubed I cubed is equal to I
squared times I to the first I squared
we know is negative 1 times I is
negative I so this would be 2 times 4 is
8 times negative I which would be
negative 8 I
and then over here I to the fourth
is equal to I squared times I squared I
squared is negative 1 times negative 1
which is positive one so this is 2 to
the zero is one I to the fourth is one
times one is one now what we want to do
is we want to combine like terms so we
have
16 plus negative 24 is negative 8. plus
1 is negative seven
and we've got negative eight I
plus 32i which is 24i
and you can see it's in that standard
form of a complex number where you put
the real number first in the imaginary
second the a plus bi form and that's
your final answer so great job let me
know if you're able to get that one in
the comments below and if you want more
practice more examples follow me over to
that video right there where I talk more
about binomial theorem and expanding
binomials I'll see you in that video